[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Wednesday May 17th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
U.S lawmakers are scrambling to figure
out how to deal with the rapid growth of
artificial intelligence on Wednesday a
senate subcommittee held a hearing to
discuss possible rules for the sector
among the witnesses was Sam Altman head
of open AI the company that created the
generative AI chatbot chat GPT Altman
called on lawmakers to set up licensing
and safety standards we understand that
people are anxious about how it could
change the way we live we are too
but we believe that we can and must work
together to identify and manage the
potential downsides so that we can all
enjoy the tremendous upsides
but with such a fast-moving technology
and Congress often divided on passing
new laws will anything get done
our Tech policy reporter Ryan Tracy
joins me now to discuss what happened at
the hearing so Ryan Sam Altman was
testifying there was also Christina
Montgomery Chief privacy and Trust
officer at IBM and Gary Marcus a
professor at New York University now
recently when we've seen lawmakers call
Executives to Capitol Hill it's led to
pretty tense interactions what was the
mood at this hearing like it was very
different much more conciliatory much
more lawmakers asking Sam Allman for his
thoughts and advice about what they
should do as opposed to reading him the
riot act or asking him adversarial
questions and it really reflected the
fact that these Technologies are new and
members of Congress haven't totally
figured out whether they're good or bad
or both yet
openai founder Sam Altman he said in his
testimony that lawmakers should make new
rules around AI what exactly was he
suggesting well he said if you're going
to have an AI system that meets what he
called a certain threshold of
capabilities then you should have to get
a license for that and that license
should be taken away from you if you're
not meeting certain safety standards
around testing it before it gets put out
into the wild for millions and millions
of people to use he didn't really Define
exactly what he meant by capabilities
although at one point he mentioned a
couple things like for example if it
could be used to create a biological
agent or something like that he also
said he wanted a new agency to be
created to enforce all this and that was
an interesting thing for him to endorse
and you know that's further than others
in the industry have gone including the
representative of IBM at the witness
table who said she didn't think a new
agency was the right way to go all right
Ryan I want to talk about some of the
big issue issues that have raised
concerns around AI let's start with the
issue of jobs how did lawmakers and the
witnesses address the issue that AI
could really upset the employment Market
you know lawmakers are clearly concerned
about that and on that topic and a lot
of the other arms Altman was really
trying to project this air of optimism
he acknowledged and said explicitly that
this technology will automate away some
jobs he also said that the future world
that we're headed for could be a better
world you know that existing jobs could
be better in some ways and that there
will be new jobs created
so he was sort of trying to talk
lawmakers out of the idea that this is
all doom and gloom you know but he's not
entirely sure that happy future is going
to happen either especially if the
government doesn't do anything
another big issue that lawmakers raised
was concerns about how AI could impact
elections can you talk a little bit
about what they were specifically
concerned about and how the witnesses
addressed it
well
at the outset of the hearing Senator
Blumenthal from Connecticut who was the
chair of this hearing played an AI
generated recording of his own voice
talking about artificial intelligence
and some of the potential benefits and
harms too often
we have seen what happens when
technology outpaces regulation
the unbridled exploitation of personal
data the proliferation of disinformation
this is not the future we want
if you were listening from home you
might have thought that voice was mine
and the words
from me but in fact that voice was not
mine
the words were not mine
and the audio was an AI voice cloning
software trained on my floor speeches
you know he was clearly in some ways
marveling at how accurate it sounded but
he also pointed out you know what if
this was my voice but it wasn't talking
about something I agree with what if it
was articulating a position on say
Vladimir Putin and Ukraine that I
totally disagree with when he found that
to be pretty scary and other lawmakers
raised similar concerns around how
persuasive these AI systems could be one
thing Sam Altman said toward the end of
the hearing was that he thought there
ought to be some policy around making
sure that if there's a piece of content
and it's been generated by an AI system
that that should be made clear there
should be some notification to the user
when they're looking at something that's
fake and the academic witness from New
York University talked about how it
really creates this world where no one
can trust what they see and that's the
difficult world for us to live in this
hearing isn't the only step that
lawmakers are taking to investigate and
possibly regulate AI what else are they
doing
so there's bills being introduced
certainly every week and almost every
day it seems on various pieces of AI
there was another hearing this very same
morning in a different senate committee
about the government's use of AI the
night before the hearing and also the
afternoon after the hearing Sam Altman
is talking to rooms full of members of
Congress about this topic so there's a
lot going on and a lot of it in the
realm of discussion and conversation it
hasn't reached the level where there's
consensus around a bill that seems like
it could get enough votes to actually
pass so that me and listeners shouldn't
be holding their breath for AI
regulation to be passed soon it
certainly is not going to pass in the
immediate term because again there isn't
a proposal that has that much momentum
it could happen you know it's always
more likely than not as I've said on
this podcast a few times for Congress to
do nothing than for Congress to do
something and there was some
acknowledgment of that at the hearing
today at a couple points Senator said
something to the effect of
the industry really has a responsibility
to do the right thing regardless of what
we do and I think that's the members of
Congress tacitively acknowledging that
they may not be able to do anything
right away all right that's our Tech
policy reporter Ryan Tracy thanks for
joining us Ryan thanks for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]